as has been the theme so far throughout
the topic this is stuff that you know
but I want to resit together all this
knowledge you've sort of amassed over
the last few years put it into a arm I
guess you'd say a scheme that makes
everything fit together and also
highlight some things that maybe you
haven't thought about before
okay so here's the first thing I want to
do you know lots of quadrilaterals you
know lots of different kinds of special
quadrilaterals one of the things you
might not have thought about before is
that they're related together in a
non-trivial way like the relationships
between these shapes hope you understand
the shapes a little bit better so right
at the top here I'm going to draw what
we call like a family tree
all quadrilaterals are related to each
other in some way so if you take a sort
of any quadrilateral right which has no
special properties about it I'm going to
add on properties to this shape and I'm
going to make the shape more and more
specialized right so probably one of the
least special quadrilaterals that you
know about is the trapezium it's the
least special in that a trapezium could
still be a real random looking shape and
you don't like it quadrilateral and
geometric proofs don't often relate to
trapeziums because there aren't that
many special properties in them in fact
is basically the only one what kind of
property makes a trapezium a trapezium
chaparro types one pair one pair of
parallel sides I do want to point out
excuse me that you can add more to this
and it's still a trippy view right so as
I go down the the diagram right I'm
going to add more properties and
everything lower down has all of the
properties of the things above it so for
example everything that's true about a
quadrilateral is also true about a
trapezium because it repeated is a kind
of quadrilateral so for example there
are many things that you know about a
quadrilateral angle sum of a
quadrilateral is 360 degrees because
of course no matter what kind of
quadrilateral it is you can fit two you
can be on view you can fit two triangles
in it each of which has an angle sine
180 and so that's why the total angle
sum is 360 right so this is still true
of a trapezium because it has all the
properties here plus this extra bit okay
so you add one pair of parallel sides
that's what you get what happens if you
add another pair of parallel sides then
carefully if all you add is one other
pair of parallel sides then your
trapezium has to turn into a
parallelogram right
it may well turn into a square but it
would have to have been a pretty special
trapezium in order to do that so I'm
just going to call this right now a
parallelogram okay now from here there's
two different directions we can go in
this is kind of cool you've got
parallelogram which has all of the
features of the previous shapes by the
way a parallelogram is a special kind of
trapezium
a trapezium can have at least one pair
of parallel sides you can have two if
you wanted to okay at the moment at this
point I have two pairs of parallel sides
so what other kinds of special
properties could I add to this what else
would you like to tell me about two
sides yeah okay so I could add one pair
of equal sides but here's the theme you
kind of already had a pair of equal
sides
when you had the two pairs of parallel
sides think about it right and I'm going
to come back to this in a second if
you've got a parallelogram picture Paulo
you any parallelogram you like right it
already has a pair of equal sides here
and a pair of equal sides here right so
in fact to add one pair of equal sides
you've already got those what you really
are thinking of is two pairs of equal
sides that are equal to each other what
does that mean
if they're all equal to each other what
kind of shape do I have this is a
rhombus isn't it so if these two pairs
of equal sides that I had before are now
equal each other now all the sides are
equal to each other that's what makes a
rhombus okay you want to add some
properties to this before we come over
here you want to make the this shape
more special there's only one more to go
what could you do to a rhombus to make
it even more special than already use
definitely okay so we've got equal sides
but if I make all the angles equal as
well equal angles then remembering that
the angle sum of a quadrilateral is 360
if they're all equal then they're all
equal to 90 so what's a shape the square
okay this gap over here there's
something in here for a parallelogram
you can do more than just getting equal
sides right you could do the angles
first right so if you take a
parallelogram and you make all of its
angles equal what a parallelogram where
all the angles are the same that's a
rectangle all the angles are right
angles which in fact is what rectangle
means it means right angle like that
defy you make something right how do you
get from a rectangle to a square
what do you add yeah it's the equal side
thing we're talking about before okay
now almost done excuse me you'll notice
I had like the gap over on the left I
deliberately um yeah the order we do
Dignam is a bit funny but anyway I
deliberately left this gap over here
because there's one shape we haven't
named yet the kite the kite now you
don't get to the kite by taking a
trapezium and adding features to it okay
so that's why I'm going to put this guy
off on the side kite
what makes a kite special what do you do
with a client to make it different
what's it got I'll come to the diagonals
in a minute we will talk about diagonals
but usually what's referred to like the
thing that makes it look like a client's
is that you've got a pair of equal sides
here and also a pair of equal sides here
okay so I guess it's something like this
but it doesn't have all of the parallel
mr. added as I went down this track okay
so two pairs of equal signs okay
which means that there's actually a
funny relationship between the kite and
the other shape which has these pairs of
equal sides the rhombus okay namely what
charities mentioned if you join us off
the kite can you draw a little kite or
from the side here maybe next to your
spot in the diagram where it says kite
if you draw diagonals what you'll find
is that they're perpendicular they have
to be okay the first time that this
occurs on the rest of the diagram is
where I said there was this weird link
the rhombus so if you draw yourself a
rhombus you'll notice again if you've
drawn a decent ramas then you get these
perpendicular diagonals which by the way
is why the formula for area which is
what comes after all of this the formula
for area of a kite is the same as the
formula of the area of a rhombus they're
the same formula half x y where x and y
are your diagonals and half a line
sometimes they're written as half a B
which sort of disguises the fact that
they're the same formula but that's
frustrating it comes from these
properties being the same okay okay so
that's all just to remind you of what
all these shapes are I don't make one
final comment as you get into these
proofs which is just to distinguish
between these two things properties and
sufficiency conditions properties are
features of a shape so we've named a
whole bunch of them here see these right
it's like Oh what makes a rhombus of
rhombus one of the things it's got all
equal sides okay that's one of its
properties okay that also happens to be
wanted sufficiency conditions so if you
have a shape and you don't know what it
is but you prove that all of its sides
are equal then that is sufficient as a
condition to say this must be a rhombus
can't be anything else it can't be just
a trapezium it has to be more special
than that because you've proven all of
these extra things okay but properties
and sufficiency conditions are not the
same thing for example here's arm just
the counter example for you right a
square has all angles equal to 90
degrees right so if you're given a
square in a question and you want to do
something with angles you can stake that
like you can pick out any of these
angles and say this must be 90 degrees
reason I am appealing to this property
of a square this is true okay so this is
a property but this is not a sufficiency
condition for a square think about it if
you have a shape and you don't know what
it is
and you prove that all the angles are 90
degrees you haven't that's not enough
that's not sufficient to prove that it's
a square do you see that I don't know
enough yet
what have I proven if all the angles are
no degrees I've proven that it's a
rectangle because that's part of the
essential nature of that shape okay so I
guess I would say what this is not a
sufficiency condition for square okay
this one that I was referring to you
just now write the fact that sometimes
you get a quadrilateral and it's
diagonals are perpendicular there that's
really cool because we've saw that scene
that and call it geometry it's a really
quick way to get to something because
you don't have to worry about four sides
you just worry about these two and
that's quite convenient often okay if I
had a shape and I didn't know what it
was and I proved that it's diagonals
were perpendicular
I prove that its diagonals perpendicular
what's that a sufficiency condition for
is that sufficient to show that it's a
rhombus it's not even though it's a
property of a rhombus it's only
sufficient to show that it's a kind does
that make sense
hmm okay so I'm gonna pause there I just
need to make sure that you have this
distinction because people often don't
get that they're different things and
you should be right to have a go at this
yes no because a rhombus is a special
kind of kite so that's why I drew this
sort of funny
funky arrow going through here so in a
similar way if you wanted to prove that
something was a trapezium you don't have
to prove in fact you can't prove really
there's one parallel pair of parallel
sides but not a second pair that's okay
you can have a second and it's still at
your preview it just is also a
parallelogram at the same time okay yes
a square is just a really really special
kind of comedian just like a square is a
really really special kind of
quadrilateral okay so let me just
restate because again that nuance is
tricky a property is a quality and
attribute of feature that a shape has
all squares have all angles that add up
to 90 degrees but a sufficiency
condition is a little more special than
that it means if you notice about a
shape it must be a square or it must be
a rectangle etc right so it's not
sufficient to prove that something has
all angles 90 degrees therefore it's a
square because it still might be
something else so many thanks